an Arizona elected official is in jail
and charged with more than 60 felonies
for allegedly running a multi-state
adoption scheme prosecutors say Paul
Peterson preyed on pregnant women from
the Marshall Islands in the Pacific and
lured them to the u.s. he allegedly
promised them up to ten thousand dollars
to give up their babies for adoption
Niki batiste is looking into this story
Nikki what did you learn
Anthony good morning well so far 13
families have filed a lawsuit against
Peterson and the hope that their pending
adoptions are completed legally and
ethically Peterson's alleged scheme
involved more than 70 adoptions where
each family paid up to $40,000 for the
process the commoditization of children
officials from several states strongly
condemned the alleged multi-million
dollar adoption scheme that unraveled
this week prosecutors in Utah Arkansas
and Arizona charged Maricopa County
Assessor Paul Peterson and his associate
Linwood Jeannette on felony counts
including human smuggling sale of a
child and fraud it was a large since
2015 the pair allegedly flew as many as
70 expecting mothers over five thousand
miles to the US months or even days
before giving birth and promised them as
much as ten thousand dollars for putting
their children up for adoption state
officials say the women were crammed
into houses sometimes with little to no
prenatal care many of these mothers
described their ordeal as being treated
like property make no mistake this case
is the purest form of human trafficking
on Tuesday investigators found eight
pregnant women in raids of Peterson's
Arizona properties several more are
waiting to give birth in Utah
prosecutors in Arizona say Peterson also
scammed the state's Medicaid system to
get the mothers free health care
potentially costing taxpayers more than
eight hundred thousand dollars mark
burnovich is Arizona's Attorney General
and
you have here as allegations were a
public official took advantage of the
system and basically used vulnerable
people in order to enrich themselves
I think read is what destroyed him one
mother paid Peterson about $32,000 to
adopt her son we didn't know if we knew
we honestly would have not adopted our
son
an attorney for Peterson disputed the
charges and defended his clients actions
as proper business practices Linwood
Jeannette has not immediately been
available for comment state officials
say families who have adopted children
from Peterson of nothing to worry about
those adoptions will not be undone and
that is the little bit of good news
it's so I mean imagine hearing a parent
say we didn't know if we we had we
wouldn't have adopted our son yeah I
know it's time to families yeah how did
authorities even find out about this so
a state trooper said he was first
alerted by a friend who had become
suspicious of Peterson's adoption
service so someone had come forward
Peterson in just one state faces more
than 300 years in prison all right
Nickey thank you very much